and that thin theological view that some
Christians have of what it is to have
faith is profoundly wrong it is
unbiblical and and that's where we have
drifted to this idea that people say I
can be against something in my mind but
I don't have to do anything about it
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening
today I'm speaking with author speaker
radio host an incorrigible Eric mataxis
we discuss his most recent book a letter
to the American Church
which argues that it's a betrayal of
Faith to stay silent in the face of
tyranny we parallel the rise of the
wannabe Arbiters of speech across
history against those making themselves
manifest today
and detail the responsibility to act
against falsehood that's an intrinsic
part of the abrahamic tradition although
increasingly non-existent in the
American church today
so you recently wrote letter to the
American church I released a podcast a
while back or I guess it was just a
monologue which was message to
Christians
and uh so obviously
to some degree we're thinking along
parallel lines Why did you think it was
necessary to write
a letter to the American Church what did
you mean by the American church and uh
tell us about the letter and what the
consequences of writing that was that
was 2022 that was released right
yes
um
I uh
I'm I'm large uh I contain multitudes
you know who said that
I believe it was Chris Christie just
kidding uh I I'm very eclectic I'm very
eclectic and I have to tell you that
um some people know me principally as a
writer because I've written whatever 14
plus books many children's books uh I do
of course
um radio show TV show and so on and so
forth
but almost everything that I do I do for
everyone in other words I'm trying to
reach uh a broad audience not just I
want to sell more books but because I I
feel God created me to speak to a
popular audience to to a wide audience
this most recent book which is my
shortest book letter to the American
Church
um is the first time I have ever written
something specifically only for those
who claim
to be Christians
I thought to myself well I shouldn't say
I thought to myself I've I had a I had a
number of thoughts rambling around in my
head that became increasingly
highlighted uh in a way that I couldn't
uh I don't know how some people will
take this but but I've never felt
God called me to write something the way
he did this book in retrospect all of my
books Bonhoeffer and so on and so forth
it's it's it's exceedingly clear to me
that God's hand was in my writing them
but never have I felt a burning passion
that I knew was God calling me to write
this specific book so it's a strange and
unique thing in my experience there's a
uh you know if you think of of the title
letter to the American Church it would
be natural to think what kind of hubris
are we talking about here that somebody
would dare uh to write letter to the
American church as though he's a modern
day Paul or something like that but on
the contrary because I felt it was God
wanting to say this uh I had more
humility than ever in writing it
thinking that I cannot get this wrong I
have to really be sure to take myself
out of the way as much as as possible to
to let God say what he wants to to say
and I don't mean this in any mystical
sense but I was very
um soberminded to write something with a
title letter to the American church and
the reason I wrote it in a nutshell is
that
um in 2010 I came out with my my longest
book a biography of Dietrich Bonhoeffer
the German Pastor who was involved in
the plot to kill Hitler
um I knew when I was writing that book
uh that it it sort of I could I could
smell what was happening as I was
writing that book I could smell that in
our future in the west not just in
America but in America specifically and
in with the events of the last few years
uh let's say the last three years
um it was impossible for me to avoid the
thought
that
just as the Silence of the church in
Germany
opened the door to Hell on Earth which
we now know because we know what
happened and of course I documented in
my Bonhoeffer book and in this new
booklet to the American church but I but
but the thesis of this book letter to
the American church is that precisely as
the German church was silent and
precisely as that opened the door to
hell to every kind of evil it is the
silence of the church in America now
this minute that is similarly opening
the door
to hellish uh things
on a number of fronts the the parallels
are so marked even the parallel of the
excuses given by uh theologians and
Christians in the 30s who said we don't
want to speak out against Hitler we
don't want to these are our reasons
dramatically similar parallels
among many uh evangelicals and others in
the American church today for why they
are being silent on issues that they
ought to be screaming about issues that
you and others have shouted about the
evil of the transgender uh lunacy and on
and on and on and on so I I said to
myself I can't believe it but the
parallels are are so dramatic uh to The
Silence of the church in Germany that I
am just burning to to speak this
hoping and praying that God in his grace
would use it to wake up those who might
be awakened we know that some people
will insist on sleep walking to the
abyss that they're they they cannot be
reached but I know that in Germany in
the 30s there were many good pastors who
got this wrong many good pastors who
were fooled
um deceived uh who allowed themselves to
be deceived until it was too late many
of them woke up and then it was too late
to do anything so I wrote this book
hoping to reach those specifically who
call themselves Christians who dare to
call themselves Christians uh with the
idea that they would say yes I have been
complicit in my silence in my inaction
uh these excuses are not biblically
based I must speak out
okay so let me ask you there's a lot
there so
let me go through some of the questions
that we might address I'd like to know
what you mean by God's hand say rather
than your hand in your writing and
so that people can understand exactly
what you mean by that and how that
appears to you and how you distinguish
your voice let's say from
from the spirit of inspiration
then I'd like to know
what events of the last three years that
you you think are particularly
problematic because there's no Hitler
staring Us in the face at the moment so
that's the obvious historical parallel
there's systems of Warring ideas and and
you're you're on the Christian side of
that war let's say you said dare to call
themselves Christian which is an
interesting uh an interesting phrase so
let's start let's start with
your description of some of the books
that you've written is that you know
they were inspired you know and my sense
is that you can separate out
an attempt to write a book for
instrumental Reasons from an attempt to
write a book to put forth what you
believe to be true right now they're
mingled a little bit because you you
sort of have to select your audience
although
when I wrote myself everything is by
definition mingled there's there's no
yeah there's no getting around that
unless unless you know a a demon is
speaking and you're doing automatic
ghost writing or something like that in
other words the we are created in God's
image and inevitably you can say this
about the New Testament itself about the
New and Old Testaments I mean they're
inspired but Paul does not erase his
personality to speak uh for God God
created Paul with his personality so
that God could use the medium of the
human being that is Paul to to say what
God has to say so it's it's different
from you know there are people I know
who will hear the voice of God they will
hear God speak a sentence or speak a
scripture or something
um I'm not talking about that uh that
happens but that didn't happen to me for
me it was and it's a funny thing it's
like develop a muscle where you become
increasingly sensitive to uh you're able
to use it and and I think literally over
the decades I've become more sensitive
to um
in other words in the past I think uh
you know I've since I became a Christian
uh you know rather dramatically in 1988
I have all I wanted every moment God to
use me to to use me in my gifts uh uh
which are strange and various and I and
I've always uh
assumed that that he would and that he
was doing that and in the various books
that I've written and the various things
that I've done even in the jokes that
I've cracked that God is with me but
um
over the over the years
I've become a little bit more sensitive
to these moments where I feel I would
say you know God is particularly in this
I can sort of feel it it's almost like a
highlighter going over something the
words are the same but you could sort of
see this highlighted the text is
highlighted or something like that I
don't mean that specifically with with
my books I'm speaking about talking
about my thoughts and things that I
think that these these thoughts feel
like God is uh particularly behind them
could I be vager I'll try no no no no no
no this is a hard thing to get right so
you know there's going to be some
wandering about in the darkness trying
to get it right I mean one of the things
I try to do when I'm speaking and also
when I'm writing is to feel I I would I
wouldn't use a visual metaphor for me
it's more like feeling my way forward
for toe holes I the image that always
comes to mind for me is walking across a
swamp of dirty water where there's Stone
pathway underneath and then you can feel
out with my feet if the next thing I'm
standing on is well water or or
crocodile or or solid ground and I'm
always searching for that sense of
solidity
but it's interesting there's a
presupposition in what you're saying
that there is a path forward there's a
right way in a wrong way and that's
that's a presupposition that you've just
put out there in other words you operate
with that piece of position there's such
a thing as truth
and I don't want to get it wrong and
that alone is right is a big thing to to
put that out there right well I would
say that well I agree well it's truth
right well I think that's Akin in some
ways to to your claim that you're you're
attempting to be directed by as close as
you can manage to divine inspiration
when you're writing I mean it isn't it
isn't a set of axiomatic statements like
I do believe but forgive me for
interrupting but it's gonna it's gonna
sound like I'm claiming that that I'm
being led by God and everything I write
I don't want to say that I'm just
basically I'm I'm a writer I'm a speaker
I do my best the only time uh I felt
something more palpable of of God's
inspiration was in writing a letter to
the American church I I felt like I've
never written anything as
as sobering
and Urgent and so I had a more keen
sense that I really need to get this
right because what I'm saying is so
serious and and so urgent uh so but I
don't want to imply that there was
anything uh mystical about it or that
every word was uh you know chosen by God
but I just had I suppose a sense of
humility something
there is something
I suppose mystical about that intuition
that
there's a distinction between words that
are false and words that are true yeah
and it isn't easy exactly to describe
how you know the difference I mean you
know the difference the way you know the
difference between truth and falsehood
if you do in fact know that difference
and haven't clouded your mind up too bad
it's no different than the instinct to
know what's it it's no different really
than the instinct to know what's funny
if you're a jokester right right I am to
know the timing of why would it be
funnier if I hesitate if I if I if I if
I if I stutter the phrase uh why will it
be funnier that the timing all those
things are instincts that uh we all
develop in our various ways
through life or at least ideally we that
we would so it has something to do with
that it becomes it doesn't feel
conscious uh it it feels like something
that it's it's an inner knowing a sense
of of things but uh I mean I've I've had
numerous genuinely mystical experiences
uh miraculous experiences
um but that's not what I'm talking about
here here I'm talking about just what it
is to be a writer uh but as I say it
kind of became pointed with letter to
the American church because of the
seriousness of what I was writing well
okay so let's let's turn to that now
because of the seriousness of what you
were writing and you pointed
specifically to the events of the last
three years and this is probably we'll
get this whole discussion canceled on
YouTube by the way good because that's
increasingly happening yeah well three
they've taken three of my videos down in
the last month by the way
um so
um what is it exactly that you think is
afoot why do you think it's akin to the
source of things that were happening
while the totalitarian state was rising
in Germany and you've just you've just
said it
the YouTube canceling
your your conversations
how extraordinarily Preposterous and
sick is that it's mind-bending that in
the west we would have some Arbiters out
there deciding what is okay and what is
not okay that's despicable as speaking
as an American it is profoundly
anti-American I think of the blood of
patriots who died for freedom for
freedom of speech so it is on the one
hand deeply offensive to me in that way
but as a human being it's deeply
offensive to me uh as a Christian it's
offensive to me because I believe that
we are all free to speak truth so the
idea that we would be alive at a Time in
the West where in places like Canada and
America and the West
somebody would dare would dare to be
shutting down what you and I and most
people know
are perfectly wonderful conversations we
know that it's not like well yeah I
guess they had a point they had less
than no point
and by my show the Eric matax's show was
flourishing on YouTube uh
getting more and more subscribers I'm
very eclectic so uh I'm you know some of
it is comedy some of it is serious
discussions about faith some of it is
politics some of it is I'm interviewing
uh uh authors about their books
two years ago I dared to have Naomi wolf
who was one of my classmates at Yale uh
liberal feminist I had her on the show I
interviewed to talk about I know yeah to
talk about yeah vaccine I didn't even
choose the subject
I had a few other people on the show to
talk about some things but the show was
not focused you know on on those kinds
of things but you too
wiped my program out completely didn't
just take some videos down wiped the
entire program the Erica Texas show
ceased to exist on YouTube and I thought
to myself if you're standing back
objectively looking at the situation
you'd say well that's interesting why
would they do that in other words this
is not uh this doesn't look good for the
people at YouTube they look like
fascists they are acting in a fascist
way they are globalists they are uh
cultural marxists but of course there's
a good dose of fascism in there they
don't believe in Freedom they don't
believe in free speech they have an
agenda and they have tremendous power
which they are now using because as we
all know they are scared to death of the
truth they are so scared that they're
willing to look like the monsters that
they are because they have nothing left
to lose so when we say what are the
parallels to to Germany in the 30s you
don't suppose that in 1933 most people
knew what was coming nobody could have
dreamed of the death camps I mean they
didn't discuss the final solution for
another eight years uh nobody saw what
was coming but people with eyes to see
people like Dietrich Bonhoeffer they
could smell this they said
um if you follow the dots they lead in
this direction the people who are
seizing power now and being allowed to
seize power now by cowardly people by
confused people
those people trying to seize power when
they get the power they're going to use
it for very Wicked ends their
presuppositions are the antitheses of
our presuppositions they are atheistic
they don't believe in good or evil
they only believe in power and and the
cultural Elites the globalist cultural
Elites today are working with the same
presuppositions they couldn't care less
about the things that most of us would
would take for granted the Dignity of
the human being the sanctity of Life all
of these things that people have uh
lived for and died for they are not only
uh not interested in those ideas they're
at war with those ideas and
so there are you know some parallels
that we can make and some that we can
make but but basically we you and I have
never seen anything like this in the
west and it's it's it's astonishing the
speed at which these things have been
happening in the last week YouTube took
down my discussion about what is a woman
and Associated issues in that direction
with Matt Walsh and they took down a
video that was a year old that I did
with Helen Joyce who's an economist
journalist and a very credible person on
the
trans minor surgery scandals in the UK
which have resulted in the change of a
number of UK policies not that podcast
specifically but those issues but most
relevant as far as I'm concerned they
took down a discussion I had with Robert
F Kennedy and the reason for that in
principle was he veered into the
vaccination criticism domain and you
know it's not like
I walk arm and arm across the desert
with Robert F Kennedy I think he's an
interesting person he's a bull in the
china shop just like Trump and God only
knows what he's up to or what he'll do
but but here's the issue he's running
for president and he's in the middle of
a presidential campaign and YouTube took
down one of his videos
and I'm looking at this from outside my
country Canada is as screwy as you can
possibly imagine and then some but I
never expected to see this in the United
States that a corporation would
interfere with an ongoing presidential
candidates in the United States is it I
mean when you're dealing with Google any
of these companies they are and this is
an interesting thing and this is why if
you're a for money you don't care
whether someone is patriotic or has any
Fidelity to American principles and most
people most politicians don't care uh
but we need to care so the idea that you
would have Google uh allying itself with
China and uh you know as I say why
for money okay what could be more
difficult well you know I well no no I
can tell you something that's more
Despicable than that I think that if
you're whoring for money so to speak
that there's actually something
predictable and admirable about that and
let me lay the argument out okay partly
because if I know that you were are
actually motivated by money and even if
that's your single there's there's
nothing wrong with being motivated by
that but you you and I know that there
are limits if somebody says
um you know it's like that scene in the
third man uh if I know I can make a
certain amount of money Orson welles's
character you know if a few of those
people disappear who cares in other
words this has always been the question
right somebody says well you you can
make a lot of money but it's going to
involve you're aligning yourself with
people who are torturing and murdering
and sexually abusing people are you okay
with that
most people would say I hope no some
people say well I don't know
um but the point is what we're talking
about right now is people who are
looking the other way they would gladly
do business with slave Traders they
would gladly do business with the Nazis
if they could make a buck they cynically
some of them believe listen if I'm not
going to make a buck here someone else
will I might as well make a buck and
that's what we're dealing with now with
all of these globalist corporations well
I think it's worse on the YouTube front
because they've left me alone up till
now
and I think that what they're doing to
buttress their ideology is actually
counterproductive at least in this
situation on the economic front the
thing that frightens me about the
YouTube video log types is that I think
that they would act even against their
own narrow economic self-inter correct
push their damage well that's what I
mean by worse if you're honestly
greeting I agree with you no no no no
okay I agree with you okay but the point
is it's mixed the point is yes when
Hitler
uh took over in in the 30s
um some people it's just like today's
exactly like today because this is human
nature they simply didn't want quote
unquote any trouble so they were willing
to look the other way when something bad
was happening there were some people
didn't want to lose their job so there's
an economic thing but the point is evil
never operates in a vacuum it works with
things like human interest and the
question is
there's this amalgam of things going on
for some it's purest greed how much
money can Pfizer and Company make they
don't give a damn about the side effects
or the what they're people who are in it
for the money and there's so much money
that they're willing to look the other
way
there are other people who are pulling
the levers uh other people that uh
couldn't possibly need more money
whether it's George Soros or Bill Gates
so it's an amalgam of things and we're
dealing with all these things we're
asking the question how does evil
operate that's how evil operates in in
every kind of way and every single
person
has a choice whether to participate or
to say I refuse to participate I would
rather do the right thing uh and trust
God with the results and that's why in
letter to the American church I'm
writing specifically to those people
Christians who claim uh to believe in in
the god of the Bible to believe that
Jesus defeated death on the cross well
if you believe that you are going to
presumably behave differently uh because
you believe that because you have okay
so you said okay you said something core
there you know
um and I finally scored to no no no no
no no no no we're just getting closer
and closer to the point which is a good
thing to do in a discussion so you
you're implying and also stating
explicitly a theory of Christianity and
one of the key points that you just made
was that if you have faith which by the
way I think is a form of courage it's a
form of existential courage it's a
decision to stake yourself on something
you will you said
do the right thing and let God care take
care of the consequences okay so my
understanding of that is that
I've been I've been trying to
conceptualize faith I suppose to some
degree and you know the atheist types
and the materialists think that faith is
the willingness to suspend disbelief in
the service of a fairy tale and I think
that faith is something entirely
different than that I think it's
the willingness to stake yourself on the
truth in the faith that whatever happens
when you tell the truth is the best
thing that could possibly happen and not
regardless of the short-term
consequences right because people lie
because they want to manipulate the
short-term consequences they think they
can get away with it they think they'll
gain something from it okay so I think
no no you tell the truth and sometimes
you're going to pay a price for that but
it's nowhere near as much of a price as
you're bloody well going to pay if you
lie now you might be too stupid and
willfully blind and naive and crooked
and devious and deceptive to understand
that but doesn't mean you're right so
this so you said do the right thing and
let God take care of the consequences
well that's the statement of faith now
this letter you wrote is that the
message that you're sending to the to
the American church are you telling
people say what you believe to be the
case or suffer the consequences is it or
is that is that the central issue uh in
a word yes yes uh those were that was
two words but it was the same word so it
counts as one word yes uh that's the
thesis if someone claims uh to believe
in the god of the Bible which I do
um then there's no question that God
requires of us to behave
as though we believe what we claim to
believe and one of the Theses of my book
letter to the American church is that
just as the German Church drifted
tragically
um in its conception of what is Faith so
to the American church has drifted in
other words they have adopted a kind of
uh Enlightenment rationalist view of
faith faith is what I believe which
means what I what I believe
intellectually I sent to I assent to
these ideas so I ticked these boxes
these theological boxes somebody says
what do you believe and they say well go
go to the website of my church there's a
statement of faith that's what I
believed well that's a fig Leaf it does
not fool God it does not fool the devil
if you actually believe
what the Bible says what the Nicene
Creed says if you actually believe those
things you will behave as though you
believe those things it will affect your
life you will live with courage
um because you know too much not to live
with courage you're afraid of living
fearfully
so I thought to myself that idea
Bonhoeffer wrote a book uh the cost of
discipleship where he famously talks
about cheap Grace because the excuse
given by the Germans uh the theologians
and and pastors at the time was that
well uh it's all about Grace it's it's
less about what we do because Luther
said oh we're not saved by our works
well congratulations you're correct
you're not saved by your Works however
there is a little scripture in the
Epistle of James that says faith without
works is dead in other words if you're
foolish enough to believe that you can
have faith and not events it
in how you live
then you're a fool then actually
biblically you have no faith and so I
think that that bad idea about Grace and
Faith which you know we we get and again
these are always you know these are good
ideas taken to extremes right oh you
know faith is what I believe uh yes
that's that's a nice idea but it can
become unmoored from the reality that
what you believe has to be lived out it
has to be an integral part of of who you
are it has to be holistic and and the
Germans were particularly guilty of this
and what I'm saying is that the American
church is particularly guilty of this
today and it's always manifested in the
idea that oh we shouldn't be political
and I thought to myself what that's
preposterous if if if you're against
slavery uh and you you live in the mid
19th century uh people will say oh
you're you're being political just stick
to the gospel well that's what Hitler
said to the pastors just stick to your
little your little gospel I'll worry
about the Third Reich I'll worry about
everything else you just worry about
your little Theology and that thin
theological view that some Christians
have of what it is to have faith is
profoundly wrong it is unbiblical your
theology has to be lived out it has to
be integrated into every part of your
life
um and and that's where we have drifted
to this idea that people say I can be
against something in my mind but I don't
have to do anything about it I don't
have to live out my life heroically I
don't have to put my life on the line I
don't have to put my career on the line
if you believe these things then of
course you have to put your life in your
career on the line otherwise it's
obvious you don't believe these things
the Bible is a root of wisdom
inspiration and spiritual nourishment
the Hallow app empowers you to explore
the Bible's profound teachings and to
effortlessly incorporate them into your
daily life a great place to start while
you deepen your understanding in the
Bible is to check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year available on
the Hallow app exclusively for brief
daily readings and Reflections here you
can dive into an extensive library of
Bible reading plans accompanied by
insightful Reflections and audio guided
meditations whether you're a seasoned
Bible reader or just starting your
journey hallow provides a platform for
you to engage with scripture like never
before
studying the Bible's literary Brilliance
has influenced countless writers poets
and artists throughout history by
studying the Bible yourself you'll gain
a deeper appreciation for the power of
Storytelling symbolism and metaphor
enriching your understanding of
literature across different genres
the Hallow app also helps you connect
with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth download the app for
free at hallow.com Jordan you can set
reminders and track your progress along
the way enrich your education and
nurture your mind and soul today
download the Hallow app at hallow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan for an
exclusive free month free trial of all
six thousand plus prayers and
meditations
Okay so
The Works issue this is how I understand
it you tell me what you think about this
if you would so what I thought Luther
was trying to establish and I think this
is wise is that just because you have
the Privileges of a king doesn't mean
that you're uh what walking the road to
the to the kingdom of heaven right the
mere fact that you've been provided with
or perhaps even earned that's more
complicated with a certain degree of
material Prosperity isn't uh a signal
message from God that you are on the
right side of things so you can't
confuse works with Grace or with
Redemption and you can't assume that
someone who's rich is a more moral agent
than someone who's poor merely because
they have plenty so that's the point I
think Luther was trying to make that's
my I actually I wrote a uh
450 Page biography of Luther uh and
nowhere in my book do I touch on that
idea so I think it may follow from some
of what Luther says but I don't think
principally he
I mean what you just said is an
important point but I don't get it from
Luther I mean I get it from other places
he he doesn't seem to me ever to have
worried about that that doesn't seem to
be uh on on the list of things he was
dealing with uh yeah well I could walk
back my claim I I would say then in that
that my understanding is that that's the
underlying rationale of the Protestant
claim that you're not saved by works
it's more that the works themselves and
their manifestation aren't inevitable
proof of of what would you say God's
appreciation for your existence all
right let me let me uh let me put it
this way
the the point and I think my dear friend
Dennis Prager and I would would differ
on this and it came out in your
conversation with him but I think the
idea uh you know one of the principal
ideas of the New Testament and one of
the principal things that Jesus was
trying to say
to clarify you know uh why uh many of
the religious leaders of his time were
off was
that um
what you what you think
uh your inner life is vital is is is
Central so if you write a big check to
some wonderful charity
um yes it counts it goes to to help you
know medical research for uh cancer in
children yes that's there's a reality
there but if in your heart you only did
it uh to impress some woman that you
want to sleep with God sees that he
doesn't just grade you on the externals
he's interested in your heart in the
disposition of your heart
um and so so Luther uh I mean there's so
much to there's so much to Luther but I
think the the issue is that Luther was
making this distinction what what he was
worried about was this idea that uh you
know you go through the mumbo jumbo and
the rigmarole of the church and that's
all that counts and he was saying no no
no no no no uh it is your faith that
counts and in other words right and
you're and you're making an existential
case in some ways for that Faith which
is that it's not Ascent to a series of
explicit propositions but a mode of
conducting yourself in the world and
part of that mode is that you say what
you you say what strikes you as true
that's what you do that's how you live
your life and if you do that well that's
part parcel well it reveals Christian
faith yes it reveals that you a that you
believe there's such a thing as truth
and B that you believe that the author
of that truth who is god
um is with you in this in other words
you don't say well hey I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna do this because it's the
noble thing it's like no no I believe in
a reality where God is with me and only
with me when I
speak the truth and live the truth and I
can trust him with the results
um trust yourself how do you trust
yourself like so fair enough I I buy the
argument I I think it's I think it's
accurate I think it's the most accurate
argument some ways but then you come to
the next problem which is well there's
God and then there's you and you're just
a confused human being and so how the
hell how do you take steps to ensure
that your judgment about what
constitutes the truth is reliable even
in your own eyes
well first of all you have to want it to
be you have to care you you have to uh
have enough humility to know that you
could get it wrong
um and therefore to cast yourself on God
and say Lord help me because I know that
I'm a fallen sinful uh human being I got
that much that's clear to me and so it
without your help I will screw this up
um so so it's it's um this is part and
parcel of what it is to be free you know
that that it comes with risks you can
get it wrong but to be cynical and not
to try to get it right is really wicked
so this cheap Grace you talked about too
which so so I have this interpretation
of I'm sure it's not unique to me but of
one of The Commandments which is do not
use the lord's name in vain and people
like to think that means don't swear and
I think in a very trivial sense
that is what it means but what it really
means as far as I can tell is don't
pretend to be doing the work of the
Divine when you're Feathering your own
nest right and I really see this as a
particularly egregious sin of the times
pride is the sin of the times and so is
deception pride and lies and of course I
think those are the two canonical sins
in some real sense but this notion of
easy moral virtue almost everything I
see on the ideological side appears to
me to be an attempt to
Proclaim moral virtue and the
accompanying status and perhaps even the
pathway to Redemption without doing any
of the work at all and I think the
universities are terribly complicit in
this because what they basically tell
students is the secular equivalent I
think of what you're complaining about
on the Christian side which is well you
don't really have to be a good person
which by the way is a very difficult
thing to do
um and the consequence of not doing that
is any everyone ends up in hell but you
don't really have to be a good person
you just have to be against the right
things and conveniently that'll require
um you know a little protesting on your
part and conveniently it will enable you
to to what would you say see the devil
and everyone else and not in yourself at
all and then you've paid your price and
you can trumpet your moral virtue and
Away you go down the road all of which
is a satanic counterfeit
of the truth uh I I was at Yale in the
80s and I saw this for the first time I
grew up in a working class home
um
uh no one had gone to college so here I
am uh at Yale and for the first time I
saw that we didn't know the term virtue
signaling but it was all there already
in yeah
so yeah what are you taking in the in
the Academy I was taking penicillin but
we can't talk about that just kidding
just kidding no I was I was uh I guess
that's how you Canadians put it I was uh
I was an English major uh oh yeah yeah
English literature at Yale yeah but but
the thing is that that concept well I
managed uh to avoid uh critical theory
and and all that although I did once
escort Jacques derida across a courtyard
with an umbrella I wrote a poem about it
but the point is that while I was there
for the first time I saw the virtue
signaling and I was taken in by it I was
young and naive and and foolish and
I for the first time saw you don't say
this you say this uh be careful about
this but you know we we don't say
Oriental we say Asian we say this is
what we're supposed to believe that
we're all of that kind of stuff and I
kind of thought oh well you know to get
along because I I have to yes but it was
there in in strength in the 80s already
and of course it filtered its way down
down down into the culture and right
right from Yale and right from The
English Department as a matter well
that's true that's quite that's quite
right quite right yeah it's unpleasant
to talk about so let's avoid it but but
um the point is that it is ultimately I
mean there's great irony irony is is the
happy way of putting it it's it's uh
think about this you're dealing with
cultural Marxism they don't believe in
God they don't believe in truth they
don't believe in good or evil they
believe in nothing but power but somehow
they have to cannibalize truth and they
have to talk about things like racism
and they have to talk about things like
that's right and that's wrong and we
care about the marginalized and of
course what we want to ask is excuse me
why do you care about those things in
others you say racism is wrong I agree
but I know why it's wrong why do you say
that it's wrong if you don't get your
values from the Bible which says that
we're all created equal in God's image
if you get your values from quote
unquote science and blind Darwinism then
who's to say that some people aren't
more evolved than others in other words
according to what you claim to believe
you have zero basis on which to make any
claims about morality about what's right
or wrong so you're gaslighting all of us
you're telling us shut up don't ask
questions do this don't do that don't
say this don't say that and everybody is
kind of
uh bullied into going along with it oh
okay okay but we ought to say excuse me
you know not only are you wrong about
everything you're not you don't even
have any basis on which to make any of
these claims so the idea that this was
uh born in you know derida Foucault
critical race Theory critical theory uh
gram sheet this kind of bubbles its way
through the decades until here we are
living with Madness on every front we
are to be pro-reality is to be a radical
in this day and age to be a
revolutionary and a radical is to be
pro-reality
so let me throw another idea at you so
I've been doing a lot of writing and
thinking about the biblical stories well
for a very long time and very intensely
recently and I've spent many many
hundreds of hours I suppose thinking
about the story of Cain and Abel which
is a story that never ceases to terrify
me right to my core and what you see in
that story is the the story of two
principalities making themselves
manifest in some way for the first time
right so you have Abel who makes the
proper sacrifices who dedicates himself
to God who looks upward and does what's
actually necessary and true and reaps
the benefit as a consequence and then
you have Cain who you know he's not so
much into the sacrifice thing and his
sacrifices are second raid and he's
trying to pull the wool over the eyes of
God and that doesn't work out very well
and so then he calls God on God's
misbehavior and says to him I don't know
what sort of Cosmos you think you hacked
together here but I'm busting myself in
pieces and all I get is misery why don't
you straighten yourself up and God says
well if you did things properly things
would probably go okay for you and that
makes Cain murderously angry and envious
and resentful and bitter and cynical and
so then he goes and kills Abel and I
think that's exactly what's happening
today is that what we point to as
Marxism is just the most recent rational
manifestation of the eternal spirit of
Cain
I think that's accurate I think you're a
pretty sharp cookie I think you're ready
to go professional uh honestly that's
the one all in man you no but I mean
that's that's a wonderful uh exegesis I
I had never thought of that really but
uh it seems to me dead on and I think
that it only took me 40 years to think
it through yes well but it's but but the
thing is
what you just said uh I don't remember
your phrasing but it's the same thing
over and over and over again in other
words we're talking about human nature
right and in fact you see this happen
even earlier in scripture uh than Cain
and Abel when uh when Adam and Eve make
for themselves aprons of fig leaves
right in other words that's the first
religious act religious in the negative
sense let's fool God uh we know
something's wrong okay so all human
beings throughout history have known
something is wrong uh how do we address
it well that's what religion is right we
say that there's this gulf between us
and the gods there's this uh break uh
how do we deal with that well that
that's what religions purport to do to
to somehow repair the breach or to climb
the ladder uh from here to there we know
we're not there we need to get there to
to Heaven uh to to some place other than
here how do we do that how do we appease
the Gods uh how do we lure the Gods uh
into coming to our Aid that's what
religion is and
in our hearts we we we we we often do it
in a way that there's there's deception
notice it's like well how do I fool God
Adam and Eve say we're going to cover
our nakedness with
with with fig leaves now
which apparently aren't a very good
covering I talked to Matthew pejo about
that and fig leaves turn out to be not
exactly the sort of leaf with any that
anyone with any any sense would ever use
to cover themselves so it's a pathetic
attempt as well as a deceptive attempt
well it's it it
I didn't I didn't know that nor is it
relevant but since it's your show we're
going to let that ride let me tell you
why the Fig leaves are insufficient
God then this is just an amazing thing
you've probably seen this but I'm I'm
fascinated by this that in the first few
verses of Genesis
it shows Adam and Eve doing something to
sort of fool God they know something is
wrong because For the First Time Of
course something is wrong they're no
longer Walking with God and they're
they've broken the relationship with God
and they try to do something about it
and God deems what they have done
insufficient and it says he makes for
them animal skins in other words blood
had to be shed innocent animals had to
be killed and blood had to be shed in
order that they could be covered which
is of course a prefiguring of the
sacrifice and the death of Jesus blood
has to be shed you think you can cover
these mistakes on your own with these
little religious acts and things and God
says no no you don't understand the
depth of the horror blood innocent blood
has to be shed to cover
what you have done and of course when
you refer to Cain and Abel it's the same
kind of thing I'm trying to do I'm
trying to do this and this this and God
and God says no this is what's required
right it has to be a real sacrifice
that's able sacrifice crisis right and
there are also sacrifices that involve
blood so imagine where we are to today
that you have people
um I mean they've effectively created a
false religion which is particularly
horrifying and wicked uh it's it's
almost like a you know we're we're
seeing it now with the with the with the
sheer lunacy of the The Pride uh
Juggernaut you know that everybody has
to be bullied into agreeing with what
whatever it is and not agree but it's
celebrating and worshiping yes
if you don't say Heil Hitler loud enough
people will look at you funny
um why you you seem to say Heil Hitler
with some trepidation Perhaps Perhaps
you don't like the fuhrer uh you know in
other words if if you don't heartily
express uh Your Enthusiasm and approval
of X Y and Z people look at you funny
and so if you don't have any
um connection to God or to truth or to
reality then you you look around and go
oh what what do I need to do so that
people won't look at me funny so that I
might not lose my job or lose my friends
what do I need to do what do I need to
post on social media what what how do I
need to uh you know out before what do I
have to not say
and so that's again you know you see
this all through history uh but the
reason I wrote letter to the American
church is because you know it's my
thesis that
Christians have no excuse uh in this you
claim to believe in the ground of all
being you claim to believe in the god of
the Bible that he you know not just died
for you but literally bodily rose from
the dead and defeated to death if you
believe that which you claim to
you will behave differently you will
behave fearlessly as Martyrs and others
have throughout the centuries that's
what's required of us and we've been
kind of drifting along with everything
you know pretty fine we kind of thought
like well we don't we don't actually
have to give our lives or or maybe lose
our jobs or whatever you have a lot of
pastors
um you know to put this even uh
more pointedly who they're worried about
maybe losing their 501c3 tax deductible
status by saying something vaguely
political from the pulpit
and I thought what kind of cowards can
you be you're supposed to be speaking
truth you're supposed to care about
people out there not just in your
congregation but out there in the world
so that if you were alive in slavery
times you would be speaking against this
satanic abomination of the slave trade
as Wilberforce did uh and against
slavery as people did and when people
say oh you're being political just stick
to theology you say excuse me what kind
of theology do I have what kind of
gospel am I preaching if I don't care
about people who are suffering Horrors
if I if I'm silent
everyone's talking about how chat GPT
and artificial intelligence are going to
change the world Microsoft and Google
are investing heavily in AI they're also
the same big tech companies that
determine your search results only now
they get to cut out a whole new layer
from the information you see that's why
I use expressvpn to add that layer of
protection back between me and big Tech
the expressvpn app hides your unique IP
address on all of your devices this
makes it much more difficult for big
Tech to identify who you are expressvpn
is so easy to use all I have to do is
tap one button on my phone or computer
to turn it on and that's it but
expressvpn doesn't just protect me from
Big Tech it also encrypts 100 of my
online traffic keeping me safe from
hackers and prying eyes and the best
part is one expressvpn subscription
covers up to five devices at the same
time so stop letting big Tech Leach onto
your data freely by visiting
expressvpn.com Jordan that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Jordan and get three extra
months free if
expressvpn.com Jordan
in Canada
and I
burst onto the scene I supposed to speak
so to speak in 2016 it was on this trans
issue peripherally but for me it was the
government was mandating a certain form
of speech right the government said well
here's the words you have to use and I
thought there's no goddamn way I'm
letting you bikers take control of my
tongue because I know what happens when
that happens and what happens is
everyone ends up in hell and although
it's sort of like hell being in
Trudeau's Canada it's not as bad as it
could get but it'll certainly get there
if everybody holds their tongue when
they have something to say I've been
reading Jonah so here's something cool
right and you tell me what you think
about this it's sort of like the Cain
and Abel situation so God comes to Jonah
and says well you got some things to say
there buddy get yourself to the city and
make some noise and Jonah being a very
wise man thinks up yours God I'm going
the other direction like anyone sensible
would right right and so he jumps on a
boat right and away he goes but the
storms rise eyes and he admits his sins
and the sailors throw him overboard and
then you think well that's pretty rough
on poor Jonah God told him to SPO to
speak and he was silent now he's going
to drown and then you'd read and you
think oh well drowning would have been
real good for Jonah because the next
thing that happens is the worst possible
Creature from the darkness of the Abyss
comes up and pulls him to the bottom of
reality itself where he cooks away for
three days and so you don't just end up
in the damn water you end up in hell if
you shut your mouth when you have
something to say
you've just given it a vaguely jungian
gloss which I will pretend not to notice
um honestly uh
these stories I mean
I don't know how to respond except to
say yes uh again
wonderful exegesis and look these
stories which are from sacred scripture
are
their uh they're fathomless you know the
meaning truth I mean it just uh it's
I I run a series
um a conversation series called Socrates
in the city
um and the idea is Socrates uh you know
being Greek I had to uh name in soccer
season City but Socrates said the
unexamined life is not worth living now
he was not a Christian but he had the
good sense to believe that there's
probably this thing called Truth we
could probably arrive at it by asking
questions and honestly trying to answer
the questions
and that again there's a pre supposition
that that Socrates has and he says it's
worth risking and it's worth examining
Our Lives when he says the unexamined
life is is not worth living and I think
you know you have to be a particularly
fearful shallow person to say I don't
have time for that I just want to get by
tell me what I need to do how many Jews
do I need to kill how many blacks do do
I need to enslave like you tell me what
I need to do oh do I need to say this oh
no now today I need to say the opposite
of that just tell me what in other words
the idea that you would you know sell
your soul for a mess of pottage to go
back to your Cain and Abel reference
it's an amazing thing and I I think if
we're honest we know we are all guilty
of that to some extent but to the extent
that you are aware of your guilt you
want to wake up others and that's what I
I'm hoping to do is to say folks those
of you who claim to be Christian this is
again I I write all of my books for
everyone and I can make the case for why
I believe in the Christian faith but I'm
talking in this last book led to the
American Church specifically to those
who already claim to believe this and I
say listen if you believe this you're on
the hook for for actually leading the
way in leading in in in leading the way
in showing people what courage looks
like in showing people that no no there
is this thing called Truth and we are
made uh to speak truth and to act truth
and we believe that you know what even
if I lose my life
I don't lose my life but you know
Bonhoeffer uh famously when he was being
led to the Gallows you know he he knew
that he says you know this is this is
the end but for me the beginning of Life
if you know
that Jesus has risen from the dead you
know that this is not all there is
you're going to live dramatically
differently than someone who's scared to
death
of dying
um and so what I'm saying to those who
claim to be Christians today is you
ought to be leading the way you pastors
ought to be shouting this from your
pulpits fearlessly all of these lies uh
all of these efforts to silence us are
satanic and by the way they are harming
human beings just as the Silence of the
Pastors in Germany led to the uh you
mean double mastectomies you mean those
human beings that is one
prominent example if you care about them
and by the way God commands us to care
about them and to love them then you
will speak up for them if you don't
you're not loving them and God judges
you as guilty and he will hold you to
account because you claim to Believe In
The God Who says you're supposed to care
about them so that's one issue one very
dramatic you know there's also there's a
a line I was just writing about this the
other day
about stripes and so Christ says if you
do not know and you transgress it's
something like that you will be punished
with a certain burden of Stripes but if
you know and you sin then you will be
punished much more harshly and this is
the situation the Christians you're
addressing actually should find
themselves in because they've already
made this claim to know right they've
already made this claim to Faith and are
attempting to accrue the status that
goes along with that and some of them
actually do know you know that they need
to tell the truth or else and the the
notion there is that if you do already
know that and you still lie
um
you're going to be punished much more
harshly than those who lie who are also
ignorant and I believe that's also true
I certainly saw that my clinical
practice if because it's partly because
if you lie there's a sin there obviously
because you go off the path but if you
know you're lying and you're
transgressing against your own moral
code then not only are you lying in the
moment but you're betraying your
innermost self right you're betraying
your ultimate core in the most real
sense and you are absolutely 100 percent
going to pay for that and so is
everybody around you this is what
verified me I want to ask you why you
became a Christian like what terrifies
me into religious submission it just
seem like this thing
yeah okay well you went to Yale and
you're in the English Department and
that was before you had a conversion
what happened to you what happened in
the conversion and why did you switch
your tune
laughs
that's the funniest way of putting it
that I've ever heard thank you for that
why did I switch my tune
um yeah I was you know I was raised in
the Greek Orthodox church and I had a
vague Faith
um at Yale which is extraordinarily was
then and of course is now dramatically
more secular hostile to genuine biblical
Faith
um hostile to uh the ideas the American
ideas of freedom and so on and so forth
I uh you know foolishly drank that
Kool-Aid and drifted into
um
genuine agnosticism and I was
dramatically lost I was really
um you know I wasn't some proud
atheistic sinner I was just lost uh and
um ultimately we could talk about this
later but ultimately
um I found myself horror of Horrors
moving back in with my parents my
European immigrant uh parents who had
worked menial jobs to put me through
Yale University and they're kind of
looking at me like so why are you back
here again what are you doing here but I
was totally lost and in that season of
my life I was 24 I got this horrible
menial job uh as a proofreader at Union
Carbide in Danbury Connecticut the uh
the Hebrew word is gehenna it was awful
and and in that misery
I
met someone who began to share his faith
with me and I was initially hostile or
at least
not wanting to hear it uh for for many
many months and long story short
around my 25th birthday
uh I had a dramatic
miraculous dream
uh in which
in a nutshell God spoke to me so
unequivocally that there was no going
back it was game over I say it's like
going to sleep single and waking up
married
would you tell me the dream
now
sure
um it's it's actually hard to do justice
to it um
it it uh
it
it encompasses three
parts of my life part of the reason it
was so staggering to me as I was having
this dream because I don't I don't dream
very much and I had never ever had a
dream anything like this this was a this
was another category of dream it was
like having a vision
in the context of a dream I was
unconscious of course I was sleeping but
um
I have to say a couple of things for the
for background so you get the vocabulary
number one grew up uh as the son of
immigrants my father from Greece uh you
know very like most Greeks inordinately
proud of being Greek and wanting to uh
raise his kids in in that tradition and
so that was a very important part of my
growing up that I am Greek that I uh
this is my my identity
um once uh my father uh we were at a
light I mean I I I I I still drive there
today and at this light we saw the car
in front of us on the bumper that had
one of those you know Chrome fish this
is in the 70s and my father says do you
know what that is and he explains to me
that that's the Greek word
for the Greek word for fish uh is is um
is ichthys and it's spelled
um you know it's an acronym well the
word is ichthys so but the early
Christians adopted that symbol of the
fish as a symbol of the Christian faith
because the word fish is an acronym for
isus Christos Theos Iman sotir Jesus
Christ the son of God our savior so they
use the symbol of the fish because to
them the symbol of the fish meant
ichthys Jesus Christ the son of God our
savior so it's the secret symbol of the
Christians and my father was you know
thrilled to tell me that's a Greek word
and that's where that comes from uh and
so I always Associated that fish with
with Christ after I saw that so again
it's by way of background fishing was
very important to me growing up also I
should say that you know if I had a
hobby other than like watching sitcoms
um it was uh it was fishing that was
very important to me so you like so all
things up from the depths
don't get young in on me you do that on
your own time okay so so yeah yeah of
course so
um basically uh
around this 25th birthday if you said
who are you you know in your guts it was
well the Greek background and my family
was vitally Central to who I was
secondly this idea of fishing this was
this was my main my only hobby the thing
that I did when I when I had time but
thirdly the life of the mind when I went
to Yale suddenly I cared about the
meaning of life and I really was an
English major
I realized even somewhat at the time
because I'm trying to figure out the
nature of Reality by reading these great
novels in the western Canon I'm putting
together these pieces to figure out what
is the nature of reality what is the
meaning of life and I was actually doing
that uh without doing it particularly
intentionally it was just instinctively
the life of the mind
um and I came up and I have to say this
so then the dream will make sense
I came up with
um you know as only a pretentious
undergraduate could do I I think I've
I've got to figure it out uh that uh
it's it's kind of like a literary Trope
it's an image of of a frozen lake uh and
what all religions world religions mean
to do
is
so this is where it becomes Freudian and
jungian and you must forgive me but
the idea of a Frozen like I thought this
is a perfect image for what religion
tries to do you have this ice on the top
of the lake
which is like the conscious mind the ice
is the conscious mind and our goal is to
drill through the ice to touch the water
which is the collective unconscious we
want to touch the Divinity the godhead
again Jung's idea not the Bible's idea
but but this idea that uh that's what
God is the collective unconscious so I
had this image that I developed you know
as an undergraduate like okay so that's
what all religions are trying to do
they're trying to drill through the
conscious mind to touch the other side
to touch the collective unconscious
which is the kind of new age idea of the
Divinity the godhead whatever that is so
I I bring all of this you know into my
24th year and around my 25th birthday
have this dream in the dream
I'm standing on a frozen lake Candlewood
Lake in Danbury Connecticut I'm ice
fishing with friends
and I look at the whole
in the ice
and I see what you never see if you're
ice fishing I see a fish pointing its
snout out of the hole and I look at it
and I reach down and I lifted up by the
Gill because it was a a pickle or a pike
they have very sharp teeth and you'd
never lipland a fish like that so I I
pick it up and in the dream
I lift it up and it's a large uh
pickerel or Pike
and anybody who knows that fish knows
that it has a kind of bronze coloring
but
on that glorious winter day the Sun was
shining brightly the sky couldn't be
Bluer the ice and the snow couldn't have
been whiter and I hold up this fish in
the dream
and I see that because of the sun it
looks golden
and suddenly in the dream I realize no
it it doesn't just look golden it is
golden it is a golden fish made of gold
like in a fairy tale but it is alive a
living golden fish and in that moment in
the dream
God effectively drops this into my head
like in paragraphs I knew
this is God saying to me in this dream
you want it to drill through the ice to
touch inert water to touch the
collective unconscious the Divinity that
God had I have something else for you I
have the golden fish ichthys Jesus
Christ
my son your savior Jesus Christ how did
you know that why did you make the
association between the fish
specifically at that point in Christ
what did that happen in the dream no
that's what I'm saying it happened in
the dream I knew but in realization took
place in the dream too the realization
took place within the Dream Within the
dream I knew within the dream that this
is Jesus Christ the son of God our
savior I had been searching for this
thing this for to touch in earth water
and God says I'd like to uh I'd like to
um one-up you with your own symbol
system I'd like to give you what you're
really looking for my son your savior
Jesus Christ a living being and when you
think about it theologically a fish
coming out of water what is what happens
when a fish comes out of the water it
dies
um
the idea that God came from his medium
to our medium
to die
um all of this came clear in the dream
and when I was in the dream holding this
fish I was flooded with joy because what
I had believed you could not know that
that the Bible is true that Jesus is God
in the dream I realized no I I know and
as I was holding the fish I realized I I
I I have I have what I'm looking for
what I was looking for which I didn't
believe could be found I this is God
he's given himself to me and in the
dream I was flooded with joy within the
dream before I woke up I knew this is
true and I just had this choice so the
next day I went and I told the friend of
mine at work the story I said I had this
dream and he says what do you think it
means
and I said
and I never would have said these words
these words would have made me cringe at
any previous day I said it means I've
accepted Jesus
I never would have said that
I
I Was Made uncomfortable by people who
said that but uh I knew that I had
jumped over the broomstick uh that I was
in another world that I had accepted
Jesus and that's you know that happened
right around my 25th birthday
what happened well that's a great Dream
by the way I mean that's that's quite
the archetypal blast you got there
that'll that'll thank you to fish around
in the dark yeah you never know what
you're going to catch
yeah I really feel like I'm talking
about Jordan Peterson uh it's it's so
yeah
it changes everything I mean I was a
different person from that day forward
my life changed very dramatically how
are you different how are you different
what changed about you well the first uh
most immediate uh embar uh somewhat
embarrassing manifestation is I
immediately stopped sleeping with my
girlfriend of three years I knew I I
can't do that that's for marriage and I
uh I I want God so that's the sacrifice
well yes and no in the sense that
you know people often say that you you
know God always out gives you that
whatever you give up for him is nothing
compared to what he gives you and I had
such a sense of his presence in those
first days of my conversion that I
thought I wouldn't give that up for
anything I wouldn't do anything to
hinder that that personal relationship
with the God who loves me and died for
me and created the universe that it it
was so beautiful and extraordinary that
you you wouldn't do anything to screw
that up you you just know that that's
not about anything well I mean and again
but I have to be real clear again I was
unconscious during this dream this
wasn't like I reasoned my way to this
and I could take any credit or
particular pride this happened to me so
this is the definition of a gift from
God uh I I knew it was a gift from from
from God and and I just thought I don't
wanna I don't want to screw that up
right right so how did you change in
your behavior you said you stopped
sleeping with your girlfriend and so is
that not good enough for you Jordan
yeah that's pretty dramatic that was
pretty that was pretty dramatic for me
at age time
I suspect for your girlfriend too well
yes of course that's that's the thing is
is that uh you know we
when you choose God you don't know where
that's going to lead you uh but it
really that's the fun of it
well that's that's correct that is the
fun of it because God that's the
abrahamic adventure eh whom we can trust
wants to take us on a glorious Adventure
he invites us to this glorious adventure
and when you turn it down you think
you're turning down some kind of bummer
and it's like no you don't understand
this is
what you were made for this is the
adventure of your of your life it's uh
what's the Pink Floyd line you know and
did you trade a walking a walk-on part
in the war for the lead role in a cage
you you're being given uh a role in in
the battle between good and evil which
is real God says come with me on this
adventure participate with me in in in
this extraordinary Adventure you've been
given the privilege to to be on the side
of good and Truth in this in this war
and you know you follow uh my banner and
you walk with me and this is what you
were created for and imagine saying no
no I want to be the star of my own show
uh you know I want I want to I Wanna I
wanna I want the lead role but you know
as Pink Floyd says lead role in Sex in
the City it's well actually it's it's
miltonic right I mean you know I I'd
rather reign in Hell than serve in
heaven
what could be more foolish
than that nothing yeah right right
absolutely well that that's that's what
I think about Power claims too it's like
because people will say well people who
use power are successful and I think
well if you're ruling over hell
and are you the least successful are you
the most successful or the least
successful and it seems to me that the
ruler of hell is actually the least
successful person in hell and that's
where you get if you use power
so you might be able to rule but it'll
be hell and you think you're the winner
but you're actually the ultimate loser
it's it's actually painful to
contemplate I mean genuinely yes well
that's why you should contemplate it
that's exactly right you know I tried to
learn the lesson of the of the Holocaust
because that's what we're enjoined upon
to do right never forget well that means
understand and that means while figuring
out how you take those first steps to
hell and then the next steps and then
the next steps and then drag everyone
along with you and you definitely do
that by lying there's no doubt about
that well I mean I became the
what you're saying you know the the my
Bonhoeffer book which
uh you know it's it's it's it's a 600
Page biography of a German Pastor who
saw these things happening and knew that
he must speak out against it and he
tried to wake up the church because he
knew that God specifically called the
church to be the conscience of the state
you claim to believe this and this and
this and this you must stand against
this evil and
we know what happened
so the idea that all these years later
something similar could be happening and
how many people have said you know we
never we're never going to repeat that
again never gonna and you ask the
question okay how are you going to
prevent it did you learn the lessons did
you learn that there is such a thing as
satanic evil when you look at the Death
Grips I mean listen that's the question
isn't that the question
they uncovered the death camps I think
most people in the world
couldn't believe it it was too horrible
it was too horrible there's something
inside us that says I I can't take that
in and I think that's what we're facing
today uh when Naomi wolf you know dug
into the Pfizer documents and you look
at the evil it's it's
too much to take in it will change you
when you see the evil uh of of
the the the Chinese Communist party's
Will To Power it's painful to look at
and yet we must look at it we must deal
with it we must ask what what is the
answer uh for us what what are we to do
you know you have to respond you cannot
look the other way but the temptation to
look the other way is dramatically
strong and that's what I think
people like you and I are hoping to do
is to to tell people no no God is with
you in this don't be afraid yeah yeah
well you can be more you can even be
more pessimistic about it in some ways
you know you can tell people
well it's going to be pretty damn brutal
if you tell the truth but boy you want
brutal you just keep lying and see where
you end up that'll be brutal Beyond Your
Wildest imaginings man that's absolutely
100 percent for sure in the course of
writing that this new book my shortest
book letter to the American church I
came to the conclusion that as horrific
as it is to think about what the Silence
of the German Church led to the Silence
of the American church now if we do not
repent and begin to speak out boldly
against every one of these things
the result will be worse even if
possible than what happened in the
Holocaust yeah well we're more powerful
now
so why not think about the whole 20th
century as a trial run
and there were no wiser obviously
because people are still you know what
did they say they still allow the cat to
have their tongue it doesn't matter if I
don't say what I believe to be true it's
like yeah well you just keep walking
down that road buddy and see where you
end up
so hey so what happened what kind of
response did you get from the church
to your book what kind of or what kind
of response are you still getting who's
to say what the church is but I will
tell you that the response has been
um very very positive
um I I'm very happy to say that because
I had no clue I didn't write this book
as some career move or a way to make
money I just thought I have this
I must write this but the response has
been extraordinarily positive uh I I am
I've never ever gotten as many speaking
invitations uh people email emailing us
daily we I bought 20 copies to give it
to every Pastor in my area I I've been
thinking this with the thank you for
saying this and stuff so it's uh in fact
later
um next week I'm I'm flying to LA to
film a documentary
uh which is this book in in in film uh
form to get the message out to a wider
audience uh because the response has
been that dramatic in fact I spoke about
this uh at a church uh in in California
some months ago and some people there
and who are in Hollywood and they said
we've got to make a documentary film of
of what you just said of this book we've
got to get this message out so I can say
with cautious optimism that uh
the the response has been genuinely
um better than I had feared uh
better than I had hoped even
um and I'm I'm you can understand why
I'd be glad to say that because I have
hope in other words I feel that there
are people joining the battle there are
people understanding you know what I got
this wrong and I see that now I was uh
you know in the early days of covet we
shut down our church and we just did
whatever the government told us to do we
we'd never seen this before but you're
seeing first of all
um wherever I'm invited to speak it's
usually by some heroic pastor and the
story is the same every single time they
say
our numbers in this church have tripled
quadrupled quintupled because we were
Brave in in the early days of covert we
kept our church open and people are
flocking to us because they say those
people must know something they they
they seem to believe in Freedom they
seem to believe in something and and and
those churches have exploded in numbers
the churches that were playing it safe
uh are withering when Jesus
right that's no church plays it safe
no
no absolutely not no the church is a
real church is the most dangerous place
you could possibly be
well that's right so that's the safest
yeah how weird is that and I well of
course well you know the truth is
paradoxical well that's just the the
nature of things but I have to say that
you know it's kind of like if somebody
says to George Washington in 1776 hey
George how do you think it's going
um you know I'm seated here on the very
Island uh uh well actually across the
East River which is not a river
um from where they had the Battle of
Brooklyn the Battle of Long Island if
you'd said to George Washington in 1776
how's it going how do you think it's
going to go
in the natural his answer would have
been we don't know if Providence before
us and we fight with everything we have
um God may give us the victory but he
wouldn't have said like hey we got this
you know it's good no and that's where
we are now we are in a battle uh for
Freedom between good and evil and our
job is to fight our job is to fight and
to look to God for leadership and
guidance and the results are in his
hands but the the response to this book
has given me reason uh to hope that we
might uh fight on and might eventually
uh win in some ways and might eventually
uh yeah what would a victory look like
you know I've wrote this on the Russian
Ukraine front but let's talk about it on
this front Okay so
there's a victory all right so what are
you aiming at what's the victory here
what is that well like compared to
what's happening now the the uh the
restoration of uh of this nation America
to
um foundational principles uh to the
Constitution the uh the draining of the
swamp that is the Deep State the
unelected bureaucrats who are at war
with we the people who are at war with
the freedoms enshrined in our founding
documents uh that would be a big part of
it
um the the idea that we would again be
free that I would go to a to vote uh and
know that my vote is genuinely counted I
wouldn't doubt that
um there are a host of things that would
happen
um our freedom to speak the truth
whether it makes people uncomfortable or
doesn't the the our freedom to question
things like is this vaccine a good idea
uh our freedom to question whether there
was chicanery uh in that election I mean
that's basic stuff that we have the
freedom to question these things and
people can say you're full of it and we
can say okay let's let's debate it let's
discuss it let's open the books let's
look into it
that's so basic and those again those
are foundational principles and uh you
know to put it on a higher plane when
Lincoln talked about a new birth of
Freedom uh I think it would look like a
new birth of Freedom uh a
re-establishment of uh of freedom and of
the promises uh you know quoting Martin
Luther King Jr no the the promissory
notes of our founding documents we have
yet to live out a lot of that uh in many
ways we've gone backwards in the last 50
or so years and so the the bureaucratic
deep State the these people that have
become authoritarian
anti-American anti-freedom I mean all of
that has to be dealt with and
um I think that you know we don't know
where it's going to go but not to try uh
not to fight and to try and to pray and
to to do that is just you know beyond
pathetic it's complicity with evil uh
and you know Bonhoeffer didn't say it
probably but it's often associated with
him silence in the face of evil is
itself evil not to speak is to speak not
to act is to act God will not hold us
Guiltless there are many people that
think like I'm just gonna take a a third
I'm gonna I'm gonna be neutral
yeah and you think no you know what
Christ says about neutral people in the
Book of Revelation
right yes that's good Cold's good but
sitting in the middle you better watch
the hell out buddy well it's sort of
funny though that people again this is
the parallel phrase no no he didn't uh
but but
in Germany this is what a lot of these
religious leaders thought that that well
there's a safe religious path we're just
going to stick to quote unquote
preaching the gospel we don't want to
get political we don't want to speak
again
and that's when you realize that the
parable of the talents in the scripture
talk talks about that that that somebody
who cynically says I'm gonna I'm gonna
take this Talent I'm gonna I'm gonna
bury it uh that way I can't lose it and
it's like no you don't understand God
requires of us to be all in if you're
not all in you're judged guilty and
there are a lot of people that right now
are just wanting to not get involved I
don't want to be divisive I don't want
to bring this stuff up and you realize
well God is is is asking you just to try
to get it right you might not get it
right but you have to try and to not try
and to just to cover your rear end uh is
ends up being Wicked because people are
going to suffer because of your silence
people are going to suffer because of
your inaction your passivity and trying
to
paint it uh along some religious lines
makes you even more guilty because
you're trying to give this religious
excuse for something that is at war with
God himself with his purposes I'm going
to bring Eric over to the Daily wire
side because we haven't we're not on the
dark side enough yet so we might as well
go there and uh we're going to talk a
little bit about how his ideas developed
how they made themselves manifest across
time we did that a little bit with his
description of his quite remarkable
dream and so a few people who are
watching and listening are inclined you
might want to head over there it's not
such a bad idea to throw a shackle so to
speak the daily wire way at the moment
because YouTube has decided to go to war
with us and Them let's say
um of course we didn't say anything
inflammatory today so just to maintain
the peace can I say something
inflammatory one final inflammatory
thing hey man I just I wanna no but just
because we we touched on so many things
and yet there's so many things we didn't
touch Sean I would like to shamelessly
ask people simply to visit my website
which is ericmataxis.com because there's
so many things that I wanted to say in
the course of this and obviously wasn't
able to but it's just my name if you can
spell it it's Greek Eric mataxis.com but
I just
um
talking to you Dr Peterson you know it's
such a joy because there's so many
directions that we can go in and so many
directions that we did we didn't get to
go in but these things are important
these are all profoundly important
beautiful things and let me just say
thank you
to you from the bottom of my heart for
being uh a courageous voice in the midst
of uh
the din around us
well thank you very much for agreeing to
talk to me today and for everybody
watching and listening your attention
and time is not taken for granted we
appreciate the fact that you're coming
along for the ride so to speak I'm going
to switch over now to uh the daily wire
side and continue this conversation and
uh well
very nice to meet you Eric I'm sure
we'll meet again uh no doubt we'll talk
again God willing and uh
thank you again for everybody who's
watching listening to the Daily Word
plus crew for putting this together
facilitating these conversations to the
film crew here in Toronto that's much
appreciated as well and uh sayonara sir
we'll talk to you on the daily wire side
thank you
[Music]